it has been too long since my producers
have tried to stump me with some woke
commercials no
well we've got him producer Ben Davies
has them lined up for me I can't wait to
put all of my
great skill and discernment to Bear to
guess what products these will
commercials are selling can we get on
with it this is brought to you by
geniusell more from them in just a
moment first though give me the
commercials I'm Ryan Butler
some kind of beauty products
yeah
as a lesbian and there's a woman
I work every day with passion when we
look at the new generations they really
expect this from the companies they want
to work for it's not something optional
anymore the only product I've seen is
this what looks like Cosmetics we
recognize you and you deserve to be
ready since it's all about appearance
[Music]
ultimately we can do more
Procter and Gamble come on that's not
fair it's not they're all proctoring
gamble I want some points for that I
could guess Procter Gamble for all of
them I'd probably be batting like 750.
I want to have a point and prop plus
proctoring able sells Cosmetics right
okay all right I'll stop litigating this
issue next one
you know that little voice in your head
the one that tells you to ignore a
tasteless joke
seeing no product yet Procter and Gamble
the one that tells you to keep quiet
when a client makes a racist comment
yeah well if it's a racist comment
against whites you better keep quiet
you're gonna lose your job the little
voice tells you you're not smart enough
you object to that at all
oh I totally agree white people are
terrible they're my least favorite kind
of people yeah
or that it's okay like a suit company or
leave them early because they have
family commitments
probably not but it's it's also the only
product I've seen here the one that
tells you not to say anything when
others are being reduced to stereotypes
or that it's not a big deal when
everyone's opinion isn't considered
yeah it's not you just want the best
opinions I think you're the only one
that hears that voice but that voice
also speaks to other people it says
you're different
you're an outsider
you lack commitment your opinion doesn't
matter can you just pause it for a
second every person in this commercial
just about is diverse
right every character is Middle Eastern
black a woman there was the one white
guy who was on the phone call but the
everyone's diver so why are these people
all feeling so marginalized are there
like two white people in their entire
office building we have to reduce that
to one we got to reduce it to zero and
everyone's still going to somehow be
marginalized I don't know keep going
instead of listening to that little
voice you need to find yours
and make it heard
there's a voice thing like a phone phone
company it's time for all of us to speak
up saying some voice like phone thing
because when we change the dialogue
we can change our world
social media
I'm sticking with a
telecoms company
thank you
RBC what is RBC it's a bank Banks wants
to empty the banks fill our streets with
banks
all right Ben Davis is going to give me
a half point because telecoms is not
really like banking at all but they're
both kind of boring corporate jobs so
okay I'll take my Half Point that's fine
I really want to redeem myself here I
also really want to look good that's why
I love Jen you sell our producers love
the ultra retinol offered in geniusell's
most popular package this nighttime
moisturizer contains a powerful retinol
alternative to visibly reduce the
appearance of Fine Lines wrinkles and
skin discoloration without the
irritation of retinol Gentiles Ultra
retinol helps to exfoliate the skin
which can reduce the appearance of pores
and improve skin texture it can also
help to even skin tone by reducing the
appearance of age spots and hyper
pigmentation
you can see results guaranteed by
geniusell in as little as 12 hours of
your money back I love the company at
first I thought men aren't going to use
this product it's all for women right
actually turns out fellas I'm noticing
that it's the guys who tend to use it
even more than the women because we want
to look good too okay love the owner the
owner is a Coptic Christian from Egypt
left Egypt pursued the American dream
great guy great company geniusell.com
Knowles YT kw-l-e-s-y-t to save up for
70 on their most popular package it
includes Dark Spot Corrector Ultra
retinol and under eye bag treatment
you'll get a complimentary spot
Essentials box with every order from now
until Mother's Day plus a free upgrade
to priority shipping go to genucel.com
knowlesyt that is geniusell.com
knowlesyt
back to the commercials
let's say an airline
[Music]
[Applause]
I think it's pretty
it's definitely an airline right they
blurred out the logo
it's an airline to hell it's like a lot
of leather and spikes and weird sex
stuff going on
board our airline to Hell strike through
the center of the earth Virgin Atlantic
okay it looked like it it almost looked
like Delta Delta wouldn't go that woke
even though Delta's kind of lib uh but
okay Virgin Atlantic that's that's it
kind of funny that's called virgins
sacrifice a Virgin Atlantic did she say
a virgin it goes straight down to the
pit of Tartarus I guess my favorite one
is the Virgin Atlantic one because all
the others try to make wokeness seem
really nice and happy and fun and that
one just makes it look like demons right
the spikes and the body mutilations and
the kind of crazy looking faces yeah I
like that I like honesty and advertising
I'm Michael Knowles we'll see you next
time don't you talk to Billy Idol that
way
[Music]